you've got some you've got some beef
with twitter that i'm not speculating
you've come out and said that your
biggest beef might be with twitter i
think you were trying to sue some of
these media outlets but twitter's at the
top of your list well twitter twitter i
tried to sue because they labeled me a
hacker they said that their their
reasoning for blocking the story from
every form of communication was that it
was based on hacked material i'm not a
hacker
so
i would because hunter gave you the
laptop he gave me permission my job was
to recover i didn't i wasn't there to
fix a laptop it was to recover the data
and then after 90 days legally it became
yours because he signed a
a bill or an invoice saying hey after 90
days if you don't pay this is now my
property and and there's no
expectation of privacy when it comes to
things you abandon so
i never felt like i ever did anything
wrong so to get labeled a hacker because
people you're going to rot in prison for
hacking i'm like i didn't hack anything
so if i'm ever going to start a business
again fixing computers
having people if i don't clear my name
in the court of law that i'm not a
hacker i'm never going to have a
successful business again so that's why
i went after twitter
again
and we beat 230 twitter put up the 230
protection
defense yeah and we actually beat them
which i think is a first my lawyer we
were high five and it was it was a good
time things looked very optimistic
and then about june they switched the
judges and then the judge
demanded that my lawyer go down to
florida to explain to her why this case
shouldn't be thrown out so that was a
not a good sign and then it was thrown
out and then i was twitter i have to pay
twitter's legal fees so can i read a
quote that you said to the new york post
maybe open up a discussion because this
has to do with section 230 media
um i believe you called the
media these days or at least big tech
state-run media
so this i guess this is according to the
post after fighting to reveal the truth
all i want is for the rest of the
country to know that there was a
collective and orchestrated effort
by social and mainstream media to block
a real story with real consequences for
the nation
is that how you still feel things
absolutely that's that's why
i'm i'm suing right now with the help of
the america project uh i i
to be honest i thought i had to move
back to delaware because i thought i
would have to file for bankruptcy and i
had to be in my house or i'd leave my
lose my house so i had to leave where i
was safe and go back to now 10 miles
from joe biden's house
and
because i don't want to lose my house
so you know
you you're you feel safe for being
closer to joe biden's house no i feel
well i still i feel safe in my house now
because yeah
it's my home and i'll like i don't know
i don't know if joe feels safer on joe
so it's not like and where does the
twitter lawsuit stand right now with you
oh no they threw it out with prejudice
and then i i owe twitter 175 thousand
dollars and do you plan on paying that
or how's that well it's mostly taken
care of gotcha i mean you're the second
most famous person that twitter's
twitter is currently suing well i'm
pretty sure they well i i don't think i
i'd want to be famous for that but
no twitter twitter was a realization i
never thought i would have my
opportunity to hold these people
accountable in the court of law so i
wrote a book about because i thought
maybe court of public opinion if i tell
my story and i put it in a book then the
mainstream media and social media can't
block it it'll be something that's
tactile and in people's hands so
i i didn't think i'd have an opportunity
again to try to hold these people
accountable uh when you look at the
the collusion
so uh zuckerberg on i think october 25th
2020 admitted before congress that the
fbi approached facebook twitter and
google
to warn them of a massive document dump
of
uh
uh disinformation from a foreign power
okay he said that
and if it was at the end of the summer
all right i i mailed overnighted a copy
of the drive to bob costello's office
and on august 28th
so if the following week the fbi is
warning
social media outlets to be on the
lookout for a document dump it it begs
the question who who has the fisa court
for that was i being monitored was
lawyer for the president of the united
states being monitored
so i want to figure out who gave the
marching orders who told everybody that
this is russian collusion sure i want to
clear my name obviously i i don't want
the mac isaac name which is a pretty
good name as far as military and love a
country
i don't need to have traitor attached to
that moving forward and i'm not going to
let them
take the narrative that they want to
push and allow that to end up in the
history books so there's yeah that's my
personal fight but the bigger picture is
there was a colluded effort there was
collusion between mainstream and social
media and federal agencies at least we
know of the doj and the fbi's
involvement to keep this quiet
and we live in a country that we're
afraid of we're leaning towards
socialism we're like we're like halfway
there with our state-run media it's not
fair and it's not right and
it shouldn't happen to the country and
it's unfortunate that it happened to me
but the biggest thing is is we should
with 86
of americans getting their news through
digital devices to have
a lens or a filter over that that's
presented to us that's controlled by a
political party
that's that's not right so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]